-Thank you so much, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, the big story today
is that following this week's
Supreme Court ruling,
Trump was forced to turn over
millions of pages
of his tax records
to the Manhattan
District Attorney's Office.
Millions of pages, yeah.
The only place
you'll find more ink
is Rudy Giuliani's sideburns.
I feel bad for whoever's
second in line
to use the copier
in that office.
Like, "Uh, how long
you going to be?"
Like, "Oh, shouldn't be --
There's only like 100,000 more.
Double sided, so maybe go get
a frappuccino and come back."
But this really is big news
because after they thoroughly
go through each document,
Trump could be charged
around the year 3000.
You can tell that they're
Trump's real tax returns because
under total loss, he still
didn't declare the election.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
We're having a good time.
Speaking of Trump, President
Biden's been in an office
just over a month,
and people have noticed
that he never calls Trump
by name.
He'll call him "the former guy"
or mention
"the previous administration."
I mean, he's even called him
things like --
-Oh, here we go.
-Tariq? What's up?
-Let me guess.
Now you're going to do a silly
bit where you list a bunch
of funny "nicknames"
that Biden called Trump.
-I mean, yeah, that was --
that was the plan.
-And each joke
will pop up as a graphic
so everyone can see it
and "laugh" about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Right, right.
Jokes work better
when there's
a visual component, sure.
-It's all so predictable.
Like, the graphic will be
a photo of Biden and Trump,
and then under Trump,
you'll list names like
LL Coup J...
[ Laughter ]
...or One Term-inator...
-Uh-huh.
-...or, uh, Don Jr. Sr.
Or, uh, Princess Impeached.
Or something like "only guy
on Myspace right now."
And then you'll close
with something
a little more risqué like...
YMCA-Hole.
[ Laughter ]
Is --
[ Applause ]
Is that how this is gonna go?
-Yeah, you -- you nailed it.
-Yeah, seems like a fun bit.
You should do it.
-Great.
Well, we'll do it tomorrow.
-Can't wait.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, this is crazy.
On a recent flight
from Cincinnati to Phoenix,
a pilot noticed something
strange in the air.
Listen to this.
-An American Airlines pilot
radios in
a mid-flight close encounter
with an apparent UFO.
-That's right.
It could be a possible UFO.
Yeah, aliens were looking
for intelligent life,
and they didn't find any
on an American Airlines flight
during a pandemic.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I love UFO sightings.
It's like...
"That could be an alien!
Or a Domino's delivery drone."
When they heard, United
was like, "Sorry. Our bad.
That was our plane.
The wings just fell off."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, listen to this.
The CDC just found out
that gyms with maskless users
are considered to be high-risk
for the spread of COVID.
Yep, the report also found
that people running
on the train tracks are more
likely to get hit by a subway.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Americans are like, "Really?
'Cause I was about to go
to Planet Fitness
and lick the elliptical!
Is that okay?
[ Laughter ]
I use the bicycle seat
as a face mask!
Is that okay?!
[ Laughter ]
I found this towel!
Can I eat it?!
Is that okay?!
Can I eat the towel?!"
Get sued by Brian Regan.
Yeah, the CDC says
people must wear masks
and put at least 20% more effort
into pretending to wipe down
the machines.
That's right.
Gyms with maskless users
are at high-risk
for spread of COVID.
And they're not the only
risky places. Watch this.
-Well, new this morning,
CDC researchers say masks
may be key particularly
to stopping the spread
of COVID-19 at gyms.
Masks are also key in stopping
the spread of COVID
at the following places.
-Oh, come on, now!
Fyre Festival 2?
I got tickets to that!
"Hot breath" competition!
That's...
Some entertainment news.
In a three-hour event yesterday,
Paramount Plus revealed
all the content
that will be available
on the new streaming service
next month.
People are already calling it
the best streaming service
next to Netflix, Hulu, Apple TV,
HBO Max, Disney Plus,
Discovery Plus, ESPN Plus,
Amazon, and Peacock.
Soon people
are going to be searching
through 20 streaming platforms
and go,
"I wish they'd invent something
where you could find
all these shows in one place,
and they should call it cable."
[ Laughter ]
But the big Paramount Plus show
that everyone's talking about
is the "Frasier" reboot
with Kelsey Grammer.
Yep, they want
to attract young viewers,
so, naturally,
they rebooted a show
about a 70-year-old therapist.
I wonder if Kelsey Grammer's
agent was like...
-[ Fingers snap ]
-"I got it!
You could be Frasier again."
[ Laughter ]
"Morty, you son of a bitch.
You did it again."
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
Hasbro is trying to be
more inclusive
by dropping the "Mister"
from its Mr. Potato Head
brand name.
Yep, it's just going to be
called Potato Head.
[ Laughter ]
I haven't checked, but
I'm pretty sure Tucker Carlson
has spent the last 12 hours
foaming at the mouth.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, if the new Potato
Head kneels during the anthem,
every person on Fox News
is going to explode.
That's just the way...
Meanwhile, conservatives
are already striking back
by releasing
a Slinky with a penis.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Some news from overseas
in England.
There are reports
of counterfeit wine bottles.
Listen to this.
-Cheap-wine lovers
are the target of a scam.
Someone is mass-producing
counterfeit Yellow Tail wine.
-Victims report that the color
and that taste were off.
The maker of Yellow Tail wines
confirmed that the bottles
were indeed rip-offs.
-Who's counterfeiting
Yellow Tail?
[ Laughter ]
The Yellow Tail people were
like, "We're so upset here,
because we know our wine
is far superior
thanks to our 30-minute
aging process."
-[ Laughter ]
-Get this.
In Washington,
a high-school band is practicing
in pop-up tents in an effort
to prevent the spread of COVID.
Yeah. Practicing is easy.
The hard part is marching.
[ Laughter ]
Parents at the concert
will be like,
"That's mine.
Green tent number 24."
I'm sure the kids
are just happy to play.
Can we see another picture?
Whoa.
[ Laughter ]
The only kid who's got it worst
is the cellist.
It's like...
-We need those.
-Yeah, right.
-Can we have those?
-Yeah. You guys --
Get the band together?
-Please, please? Yeah. Yeah.
-Uh, asked why he decided to
do it, the music teacher said...
"Because it's funny."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, we're all
bored during the pandemic,
but check out
what this Colorado woman saw
two guys doing in the snow
last week.
-Woman: Geez.
[ Laughter ]
-One of the guys was like,
"Join me,
and together we can rule
Beaver Creek, Colorado."
C-3PO was like, "I'm detecting
signs of virginity."